what do you usually picture when you
think about a banjo do you think about
the Appalachian Mountains or the the
countryside of the U.S South maybe an
image of a white man in overalls no
shoes picking and grinning I mean these
are all the things that I thought about
my whole life with the banjo the journey
is complicated but it is super
Illuminating about how America came to
be
grow up knowing any of this history that
I'm going to be telling you about I knew
none of it I knew what I suspect most
people watching this knew that the banjo
was a white hillbilly instrument that
sort of came in and then became sort of
a comedic you know idea in the hands of
like Steve Martin and lots and lots of
jokes and that's what I grew up with as
the banjo and the sound that real tinny
kind of exciting troubly very very
piercing sound that's what I knew of the
banjo
[Music]
and so all of this changed when I became
an adult I went to this what I thought
was an English country dance but
actually it was a contra dance and I
find out later that the contradance is
the American descendant of the English
country dance and I got hooked I got
hooked to the idea of live music and
folk dancing now here's where the
contact is in my region in the Piedmont
of North Carolina which is where I'm
from the woman who was putting on these
dances Carol Thompson she loved old time
music now old time music was something
that I had never really heard I'd heard
Bluegrass which is kind of what I think
a lot of people think of when they think
of the banjo that really fast you know
very exciting sound old time was a
little bit more funky it's a little bit
more relaxed it was a little bit more
for dancers
[Music]
and so that's the bands that she would
book for these dances these really
rhythmic funky there was always somebody
on the banjo somebody on the upright
bass my playing fiddle and just playing
these really cool tunes and I was
dancing to this music every week going
oh my gosh now I've never heard the
banjo sound like this the Rhythm was
different it just felt like
I don't know I could feel it in my soul
in a different way than bluegrass music
and I became hooked to the sound of the
clawhammer banjo which is what people
play in old time and I was really really
connecting to it and I've realized that
I wanted to play it wasn't enough to
dance to it and so I got a second job
and I bought you know a cheap banjo my
first Deering banjo and also a fiddle
because I wanted to learn everything I
was just fascinated with this music and
as a vocalist I had never really learned
instrumental music and so it was a huge
mountain to climb but I was like so
ready for it and so I was starting to
learn this music and trying to find
teachers and then I would call I would
go to the uh the old time jams you know
of the community of people who played
the music in the Piedmont of North
Carolina and of course as time kind of
went on the elephant in the room was
that I was the Raisin in the oatmeal you
know it was usually the only uh person
of color in the room you know usually 99
of the time it was just me and I just
started to kind of feel a little bit
like
I don't know I felt like I had to ask
permission to be in this music you know
and I was kind of like you know you guys
let me and everybody was so nice and
they're so welcoming they're coming and
look I'm like half white like I should I
should have felt any of that but I did
feel it because there's this idea that
this music is kind of The Preserve of a
certain area like the Appalachian
Mountains and the white people who live
in those mountains and it's their music
and so I kind of felt like I needed to
kind of ask permission to get in there
but then stuff started to happen like I
started seeing you know Marshall Wyatt's
uh label he has and he had these CDs
that had like black musicians on the
cover playing Old-time music and I was
like what's that so I was like oh black
people did play this music that's
amazing and then I was referred to Cece
Conway people in the community going
have you talked to Cece she wrote this
book and the book is called African
banjo Echoes and Appalachia and that
blew my mind because that's the moment
when I found out that the banjo is
actually an African-American invention
they also pointed me to a really
important person he became very
important person in my life a man named
Joe Thompson who was an actual living
proponent of black String Band music he
was a fiddler and he'd been playing this
music since he was five years old and he
lived in Mebane North Carolina which is
where my family's from I used to go down
there for family reunions every year it
did not know he existed and he was a 86
when I first met him and that changed my
life
[Music]
why these six banjos
we start with the beginning you know the
banjo that people were creating
themselves in the Caribbean which
becomes known as the gourd banjo or a
gourd banjo and everything that
surrounds the creation of that is in the
DNA of everything that follows so we
have to start there right and then we
have the traveling of the banjo from the
Black Culture to White culture from a
homemade instrument to commercial
instruments so they have then the
menstrual banjo and everything that
happens during that transition
is in the blueprint of what follows
right and then we have a continuance of
the black playing of the banjo through
jazz
but it's something that's not really
well known and it's going through an
incredibly important piece of transition
for American culture you know at the
turn of the century so made sense to
have the tenor banjo in there and then
you think about what the banjo means to
people and the chameleonic nature of the
instrument how you know different folks
can find themselves in that instrument
so it made sense to go to the Irish
banjo because that's something you
didn't see coming right and then we
think about the obvious place that the
banjo has been in bluegrass and old time
in country music and what happens with
the narrative and how it changes from
being known as a black instrument to
being known everybody knows that it's a
white instrument so we had to include
that and then you get to well where are
we today with the banjo you know there's
all of these things that are happening
now that connect us all the way back to
the beginning and so the more that I
started to learn about the history that
surrounds where the banjo comes from the
more American culture of right now
started to make sense to me you know why
is the banjo popular over here why is
the banjo being brought over here why is
the banjo look like this why does the
music and the musician holding the banjo
look like that
part of a team of people who want to
make sense out of American history and
we include all of the different sides of
it so when we step back we actually get
more of a 3D model rather than a 2d
piece of paper
[Music]
well I'm absolutely delighted you guys
could join me today I cannot believe I'm
lucky enough to be able to sit here at
this table and talk to all of you at
once because you know we have here an
instrument maker uh uh an author and
well everyone's a researcher and then
you know Greg we've been talking through
performance practice and you know
looking at the music
um so we're just going to be talking
about the work that you guys are doing
and and how it's intersecting with what
I'm trying to do with this idea that the
banjo has
came into being as a ritual sacred
object of the African diaspora as we've
I think we all agree like looking at
this history there's there's something
of Genesis moments for our cultural
history that go back to this these early
this early banjo history and as
Americans
this is the cultural era we still
breathe all the time and we just have a
responsibility to know it and
I sort of can't help myself I just I
want to know the truth of this stuff and
I just want to keep digging at it and
even when it gets into some really hard
truths
you know
I feel it's it's my responsibility to
look at this stuff there was a point in
time where people knew that the banjo
was this instrument of the African
diaspora and they knew that it had this
religious component you know that it was
a religious object thinking about
the banjo and all of the beautiful and
Powerful things that can come out of
people coming together nurturing one
another learning how to do something
the flip side is in order to really
understand that history we have to
understand America's history of slavery
we have to understand how these things
fit into America's first major forms of
popular music through the phenomenon of
blackface minstrelsy and then we also
need to understand how all of this
material that survives to this day how
does it fit into these larger industrial
motions to capitalize and commercialize
what's going on all of these identities
all of these experiences all of these
cultural tools and implements are
embedded in these very challenging
things that we all need to figure out
more Pathways how do we talk about this
[Music]
at the first black banjo gathering in
Boone North Carolina in 2005 and yes
there was such a thing it was incredible
there were two West African players one
was an ingonie player from Mali whose
name was sheikha Mala jabate
the accounting player Daniel Jato was
from The Gambia and he lived in Sweden
now watching him play and talk about the
accounting I was immediately struck by
the similarities of the playing styles
of the accounting and the old-time banjo
now Daniel says that the word banjo
comes from Bon Jo
b-a-n-g-o-e a mandinka word and the
gambia's capital banjo also comes from
this word now there's a lot of theories
as to where the word banjo comes from
but just the fact that there is a
cultural story from that area it means
everything to me the accounting is
thought to have originated in Southwest
Senegal now with the round or oval gourd
body looks like a drum it's got a stick
neck and it has three strings two were
long and they're the melody strings and
one is the short drone string so the
banjo isn't necessarily from Africa
wasn't invented in Africa but
it starts even before Africa the idea of
it because you have instruments that
come all the way from the Far East they
move into the Middle East they go down
into Africa and they go up into Europe
and they change wherever they go they're
changing as they travel with people
they're being changed by where they end
up so you have this really big family of
stringed instruments that are all kind
of related and you have different
versions in different places so you have
these gourd and Calabash type loots that
already exist in Africa before people
were ever brought over as part of the
transatlantic slave trade so when folks
were brought over as enslaved people
to the Caribbean in particular these
memories of these instruments even if
not the instruments themselves I'm not
sure exactly how many may have come over
with people but at least the idea and
the knowledge of how to make these
instruments came with these people and
in the Caribbean the idea of the banjo
started to come together because you
have all these people from different
places and it and it starts to coalesce
in the Caribbean and become known as the
banjo the banza the all these different
terms that become the banjo as time goes
on from the beginning of the
transatlantic trade in human beings
Europeans wrote about this act of music
instrument creation as they saw it on
the ships in the Caribbean and Beyond so
banjo researcher Laura Dubois describes
how in 1819 the British architect
Benjamin Latrobe who was the second
architect of the U.S Capitol sketched an
instrument with the body of a calabash
which he saw being played by black
performers in New Orleans now this was
after a hundred years of the instrument
Ari being played in the Caribbean and in
afro-atlantic communities
du bois's book The Banjo America's
African instrument explains that the
banjo was quote not just for the
enslaved to gather with one another
across ethnic lines but also to connect
with ancestors and gods its role was not
just Sonic but also spiritual its sound
accompanied funerary rights and wakes
and the musicians who played at occupied
roles not just as performers but as
individuals who convoked and channeled
the spiritual end quote so on the one
hand do you have the banjo as the
spiritual connection to the very
land that these people had been taken
from and then on the Other Extreme you
have the banjo used as a tool of
economic might right and this is going
to be a pattern that we're going to see
the banjo as cultural uh Keystone and
the banjo as commercial instrument so
you have people the enslavers basically
using the ancestors to the banjo these
instruments that existed all over Africa
and the musicians who played them to
ensure a healthier cargo because of
course slavery was all about money it
was all about the bottom line
so they would bring these poor people up
from the bowels of the ship to the deck
for this brief amount of time to dance
to this music and they would make them
dance they would use the Lash and they
would make them dance so that they would
be healthier when they got to the other
side so that these people had more money
so the other thing that we have to
understand about this time period is
that people weren't brought directly
from Africa to all the different places
in the United States there was a lot of
movement through the Caribbean the
Caribbean was kind of a deliberate
seasoning process people died at
exponential rates it was really really
horrible and it broke people I mean it's
just that's just there's no way around
it and they would bring people there
first and then they would end up in the
United States especially when the
transatlantic trade was outlawed you
know so you can no longer bring people
straight from Africa to the United
States at a certain point so there was
all this movement through the Caribbean
and what that means is that there was a
an amalgamation of cultural ideas that
were happening in an area and then there
was a migration of those ideas with
people and it made me think about how
far back this goes do you know it goes
all the way back to Africa in terms of
people in terms of memories in terms of
what came first and the culture that
this music and the need to survive
came out of
[Music]
so this is my gourd banjo it's not a
historical instrument this wasn't made
from you know a painting or a picture or
anything but I think it gives you a
pretty good idea of what a gourd
instrument would have sounded like back
then because in Basics it is pretty
similar it's got a wooden neck and this
beautiful gourd body and this is called
attack head gourd because a gourd banjo
because it is the this is an animal skin
that's been put on by tax and that was a
technique that was used as you can see
the inside there it's just really
beautiful instrument
I love the sound of it
you can hear that it's
it's deeper than maybe the modern banjos
that people are more used to
it's got a very resonant sound a very uh
organic sound uh and I'm playing it in
what we call clawhammer style so this is
the back of the nail is used for all of
The Strokes and the thumb is just used
on the Drone string so the hand in
general the hand goes down and then when
it comes back up the thumb plays the
Drone string
[Music]
that the banjo has is that it's a much
higher
the string the the height of the strings
is is higher than the modern band just
so I actually have a lot of give
[Music]
the other um the other thing about this
instrument you may have noticed is that
it is fretless
so there are no Frets that are engraved
or placed on this for a very long time
the banjo is fretless until the mid to
late 1800s and it was
had the sound of the in-between for a
very long time and I think that's an
important piece of this because when you
think about something like an Ood you
know which is which has all the ability
to go in between and have all the micro
tones and you know you're not locked
into any one thing you can do a lot of
different stuff and that's really one of
the aspects of the banjo that people
don't think about nowadays because they
all have Frets but none of them did for
a very long time so you can really
you can really like blue note it up all
you want
thank you
so when you were trying to correct
a false narrative you have to lean in on
the piece that has been obscured the
piece that's been hidden and in this
narrative the piece that's been hidden
is the fact that banjo is an African
invention it has African ancestors and
then it was invented by the African
diaspora in the Caribbean that is a big
piece of information and from that piece
there are huge branches of other
information that has also been obscured
that has also been erased but that is
very important for our correct
understanding of where American culture
comes from
[Music]
in my breath
George about to stand there's a lot of
people who are invested in this story
and we are creating a community that's
drawing other people to it and it's not
just about being black playing the banjo
but also offering up a different point
of view this is just how I see American
culture through the development of the
banjo
[Music]
what's important to say here is that
this is an inclusionary history it's not
exclusionary what it's very tempting to
hear oh it's an African-American
convention that means that it's being
taken out of the hands of white people
that's not true at all it's actually
just
widening the focus and showing the
entire story which is actually beautiful
the entire story is actually some of the
best of where Humanity comes together in
the midst of some of the worst of what
Humanity has done right because we
cannot talk about the banjo without
talking about the institution of slavery
which is why we have the banjo
[Music]
thank you
foreign